it's a funny thing about earth porn you
know what earth porn is we see so much
of it on the web and the feeling I
always get is that's something I want to
experience that's something I want to be
awed by in person the digital 1920 by
1080 JPEG version of that natural beauty
is at once
a placeholder and a substitute for the
real thing
once I'm out in nature I think I'll get
to experience that all in its most raw
and powerful form except that I don't
ironically it seems that the constant
consumption of all these digital
representations of nature weakens my
ability to experience nature as it is a
sort of barrier between me and real
things and sometimes seems that I can
only experience reality in terms of
shareable data of how it would be
packaged in a Facebook post or an
Instagram picture or earth porn or a
vlog like this maybe you could say that
I experience reality based on how I will
articulate it thereafter the only
prescription for this can be to just
shut up be still and listen quite the
opposite of film edit and publish to
YouTube but there's some people I want
to thank for an amazing weekend take a
look
[Music]
crazy dog ain't no surprise you talking
to Lucy sniffing around your don't know
crazy don't know fall travelin mailman
so like are you there when I was perfect
crazy man interaction shot do you only
cursing coach you don't kid where did it
go crazy man don't know his fame don't
know when tomorrow I want to say to my
mother father sister that I love him and
that you're always so good to me I'll
never forget you big trouble
let's run to a place far away from here
where grasses warm and real things are
you and the cloud the skies are in
sprightly we're in some absurd in the
ground your king drinkin beers watch
over ball Marcel great don't fall story
in each passing by but I love that
errands off it is so so lair thumb and
then you pan down to the finis pants
I've ever seen
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
this lady is got an old metal sled
toboggan sorry
and she's greasing it up with a block of
fat had on that was like rocks
she must be 75 or something oh my [ __ ]
she's going faced first 75 on a wax up
metal toboggan yeah do not whiners job
oh yeah